and also like an important development  in the eye in the magnus signage game  because punish ended up making the move  which we thought was just completely  completely wrong  he played ed  why was it completely wrong just rook b7  yeah is rook b7 and we just don't see  any defense against the combined threats  and he might be back to being completely  lost right  still preferable for white for the pawn  on g6 but in this particular case i  don't think it matters very much  because i i don't really know how you  continue here allowing bishop before is  resignable c5 you get mated after  queen f5 i assume or  anything  honestly yeah just anyway and it's  resigned yeah and i guess they will have  a  a fun post-mortem in  yeah the analysis area which is very  charming in vaio kansai i'm not sure how  things are in pandemic times but usually  that's that's